I hear what I one
yours now
what's up Brian so we just got back from
battlefield hardline and checked out the
new dlc criminal activity ads for new
maps couple of battle rifles some grabby
fast hand gloves say nail gun and a new
mode but it was pretty much just kill
confirmed yeah it was actually a carbon
copy of Kill Confirmed so if there is
any question that hard line which to be
fair has about eighty percent of its
audience on console is or the console
community then this is sort of an easy
confirmation of that I don't know about
the title criminal activity I couldn't
for the life of me tell you what other
than like what would make it criminal
activity any more so than the vanilla
game here we have new weapons that are
focused on the enforcer which is a class
that needed a bit of love anyway it's
basically all about the enforcer class
and it's all about new battle rifles we
got to play a lot with them one was the
sig 510 and the other was the fall but
they felt fairly in line maybe a little
bit more friendly than battle rifles
have been in hardline so far which I
gotta say has actually been a weapon
class that struggled for a place in
people's play styles we've also got a
new gadget which you mentioned which is
what i like to call money gloves oh yeah
the money grabbers which in blood money
like raid the cash pile at a speed that
is unreal it's not just blood money it's
they help they speed up your interaction
with all objectives in battlefield
hardline and it's gonna be interesting
to see what happens you know you could
be losing in blood money and then a team
with these money gloves come in and
basically rate of all instantly
instantly the official name of them by
the way is the break-in kit other cool
things that we saw in the DLC were the
nail gun which is a new battle pickup
right so if there's any weapon that
comes out of this DLC that's really cool
it's the nail gun it's a basically it's
a pistol that is suppressed and fires
nails now something that we did not like
which is it's actually not precisely
part of the criminal pack it's something
that everybody's going to get in a patch
was the m1a1 also known as the tommy gun
recognizable right like basically you
don't have the normal attachment
loadouts you basically have two options
you can run with the Tommy gun as you
would remember it from a world war two
movie as like the sort of sidearm that
like the sergeant might be carrying or
you can put extended mags on it in a
grip and you have that sort of gangster
style machine gun and while it looks
cool in either way it is severely
outclassed by the k10 or the p90 or even
perhaps the mat kehna in the last weapon
they added in was a new shotgun the KSG
12 it felt like precisely a shotgun to
me on par with other shotguns they had
these new breaching rounds in the
description that said that they blue
doors open my experience was that didn't
necessarily happen or was all that
useful for you to do and opening doors
was never really a problem in hardline
so I'm not clear on this round yet the
other new round in the game is the
armor-piercing round it does have some
shortcomings at this point so it's good
at close to medium but at long range the
tracer rounds as we saw them in the demo
came out at a weird angle and we're a
little bit too big and actually made it
harder to figure out what your bullets
were going yeah I think there was a
point on backwoods where you and I were
both on a hillside taking potshots at I
think the same target and we both had
tracer rounds on and i can tell you i
did not connect once the one question
that we had which they actually didn't
cover in the demo is what type of armor
they were talking about because the
mechanic is the only class that wears
body armor right so it was unclear
whether they were talking about vs.
vehicles or not and in which case
vehicles already go down in two grenade
hits or so my impression is that the
that these tracer rounds aren't supposed
to work the way that the snipe special
sniper rifle rounds work what I'm hoping
and again we didn't really get to test
this is that they're good at penetrating
vehicles to say
the pilot and a helicopter or the driver
in a car rather than do damage to the
vehicle itself now let's talk about the
maps weapons I was just sort of okay
about but the maps actually were pretty
good there for new maps each of them is
fairly different and each of them has
modes that are particularly good for
them so for example code blue is a club
map and we found that it was a lot of
fun on blood money yeah code blue was
actually really cool it's reminded me a
little bit of robbing the nightclub in
payday only a lot bigger and had some
great surrounding buildings when we
played it on blood money it was fun to
sort of get to the cash piles the
enemy's cash pile because there were a
lot of sort of of ways in that were a
little bit surprising like some good
wide open spaces around the edges and
some good flanking routes but the club
itself on the inside was like noisy and
dark and kind of confusing I got one
point I got shot by a guy who was prone
on the dance floor and I swear I didn't
see him because all the dazzling lights
backwoods in stark contrast is kind of a
backwater logging camp it's got these
three different objective points on
conquest and rolling hills in between
them so there's no direct sight lines a
little bit more diffused fun and Hotwire
have a feeling it's going to become a
big sniper map at some point then
there's the beat which was kind of what
the block should have been it doesn't
have the destruction but it has that
sort of like central slummy three-story
apartment block which creates a lot of
really intense vertical gun fights but
the really cool thing about the beat is
that the whole entire exterior of the
map has a road going around it and on
the other side of that road is another
almost entire block of built out
structures yeah this feels a lot more
open than the block did it's not quite
so claustrophobic that central
three-story building area is almost
maze-like not really clear or long sight
lines necessarily but then everything
around the edge is really cool like
you've got a car dealership that you can
go into there's like a self storage area
donut choose a donut shop and like all
these like areas have a little bit of
personality there's a
a station it's a nighttime map and it
looks cool the lighting is good and in
modes like you know we played it on
blood money getting from the cash pile
which is almost hard to find unto itself
in the center hidden in one of the
apartments going out from there you have
to cross a pretty wide road to get back
to your base and so you know I think
we'll see a lot of both good close
combat a lot of good sniper
opportunities because you can get on the
roof of that car dealership probably a
lot of nail again and on top of that
there's plenty of room for the cars to
get around so it's got it's a good i
think all around that the last map that
we saw was black friday which i could
only describe as a mazy mall yeah it's a
large shopping mall it's got the sort of
interior shopping area but has all of
the sort of back hallways and fired
exits and things like that and it is so
confusing on a first playthrough I could
not find my way around I didn't know
where I was any of the time the new mode
bounty hunter it was like perfect for ya
if any map in this DLC was made for
bounty hunter / Kill Confirmed it's a
black friday the mall now absolutely
lots of like corners lots of turns lots
of areas to get just ambushed from yeah
it creates the right kind of tension in
that mode where you take somebody down
and you have to make the decision
whether it's worth running for the tag
right then or not so what was your
overall impression of just should you
buy criminal activity I think if you're
still playing hard line and you want
more hardline this definitely brings
that I think if you liked it before but
maybe you took a break it's also worth
coming back but I don't see this as
something to say Lord new players in I
agree I don't think this DLC is going to
bring the pc player base back but if you
are still playing on console which is
actually the vast majority of you who
are playing hard line this does add more
content I think the maps of the main
draw all right well if battlefield
hardline criminal activity does interest
you it'll be out for premium members on
june sixteenth and everybody else on
june thirtieth
it's gonna blow